Speaker 1: Now let's jump over to Newsmax, where
Grant Stinchfield is making the other case,
which is if Tyree Nichols had just
complied and done what his killer
said to do, he wouldn't have been killed.
Speaker 4: But here are some of the facts
that people aren't talking about. This all
could have been avoided with one simple move.
Tyree Nichols could have complied from the
moment he was pulled out of that car. If you
watch this interaction, he never really complies.
Speaker 1: Until the very end. He doesn't comply
until the very end. Dum dum Grant Stinchfield
says. When was he to comply, Grant? Was it when
they stood him up and punched him in the face? Is
it when they had him pinned to the ground and got
running, starts to kick him in the head? Is that
when he should have complied? Grant Stinchfield.
It has been said I didn't originate it, but
it's been said that cruelty is the point for
conservative politics. In conservative politics,
whether it be owning the libs or whatever, cruelty
is the point. That's how you get the usually
the passions inflamed in MAGA world. And that's
exactly what this is. It's not just pathetic
excuse making for jackbooted armed agents of the
state who summarily executed an unarmed citizen on
the streets, on the suburban streets of Memphis.
It's all. Listen. If we do not get a handle on the
rhetoric, if we do not get a handle on the other
side of the aisle and their carelessness and their
lack of concern for humanity, we're going to be a
more bifurcated nation than we have ever been when
it is sport for them to act as cruel as possible.
There no conversation to be had? I'd love
to know what you think about all of this.
We could mix it up in the comments. David's got
a voicemail line. This should be a conversation
that continues in the following weeks. I am Jessy
Dallimore. I'd love to have you subscribe to my
YouTube channel if I am your flavor of political
commentator. You can go over and subscribe to the
Dallimore daily. I have a podcast called I Doubt
It Podcast or you can. Follow me on social media
at Dallimore on Twitter and
Instagram and TikTok. Thanks a lot.